يُظهر الأوكرانيون مرة أخرى
قدرتهم على الضرب لمسافات طويلة، حيث
زعموا في هذه الحالة أنهم ضربوا
مستودعًا للنفط بالقرب من مدينة سان بطرسبرغ. والآن
يقع هذا المستودع على بعد حوالي 100 ميل غرب سان
بطرسبرغ على خليج فنلندا،
ويقول الأوكرانيون إنه أمر
بالغ الأهمية.  وهو أمر مهم بالنسبة للروس
لأنهم يصنعون هناك مجموعة من
المنتجات بما في ذلك وقود الطائرات،
ويقول الأوكرانيون إن بعض هذه
المنتجات يستخدمها
الجيش الروسي، وبعبارة أخرى،
يقول الأوكرانيون إنهم يعتبرون هذا
هدفًا مشروعًا الآن إذا كانت الطائرة بدون طيار
في الواقع، كانت الطائرة قد طارت من الأراضي الأوكرانية
لكانت قد طارت مئات الأميال
عبر روسيا لتصل بعد ذلك إلى تلك المنطقة،
تلك المنطقة من روسيا التي كان من الممكن أن
تحلق فوقها، كما أن لديها الكثير من
الدفاعات الجوية القادرة للغاية، لذا فمن المؤكد أنه
إنجاز كبير من قبل الأوكرانيين إذا
طاروا بالفعل  تلك الطائرة بدون طيار خرجت من أراضي الجحيم الأوكرانية،
وكل هذا يأتي أيضًا بعد
أيام فقط من إعلان الروس أيضًا أنهم
أسقطوا طائرة بدون طيار أوكرانية في
المنطقة المحيطة بالمكان الذي حدثت فيه الضربة
الآن، وكل هذا يحدث
بينما تستمر الحرب.  على قدم
وساق أه منطقة دونيت التي تسيطر عليها روسيا
تقول إن العديد من الأشخاص
قتلوا في القصف الأوكراني يوم الأحد
الأوكرانيون يقولون أيضًا إنهم
يحاولون الدفاع ضد
الهجمات الروسية التي تحدث على طول شرق
وجنوب شرق خط المواجهة
الروس  قائلين إنهم تمكنوا من
الاستيلاء على قرية من الأوكرانيين في
منطقة هارف بينما يواصل الجيش الروسي
الضغط من أجل لين سي إن إن في شرق
أوكرانيا